All right. Well, I think we'll get started.
Welcome, everyone, to this educational session
on multimodal platforms for early cancer detection.
I think that this topic is going to be an exciting one at this year's
AACR, and I'm really, really honored to be joined by two
really amazing speakers, I think, to talk about this topic today.
So if you would like to ask questions in this
session, you can either come to the mics.
It is important for you to come up to the microphone, given the live stream, and
speak into the microphone. Also, you can put your questions by using this
QR code here. So I'll leave that here for just a second,
so people can take a picture of it.
All right. That was definitely just one second.
So
in way of introduction, my name is Kara Maxwell.
I'm at the University of Pennsylvania, and I'm just going to do two quick
introduction slides to the topic that we're trying to talk about today.
So it's no secret to anybody in the multi-cancer early detection space that
what we're trying to do is really improve upon early
detection as a way to reduce cancer morbidity and mortality.
I'm from the University of Pennsylvania, and we have a saying by Ben Franklin,
that an ounce of prevention is worth a pound of cure.
I give kudos to Dr. Bob Vonderheide, our cancer center director, as
the first one that introduced me to that, but I really do believe that that is how
we're going to make the needle forward.
Right now, we have screening programs in this country for a few
different cancers, namely lung cancer in certain folks
at risk, breast cancer, and colorectal cancer, and cervical cancer for the general
population. But as we know, each of these tests is an
individual test, and so the promise of a blood-based test where we could detect
multiple cancers at once really is the dream.
There's been a lot of movement forward in this field, and I think one of the things
that is obviously concerning to many of us is what is the sensitivity and
specificity of these tests that are coming out, and are we actually going
to be able to handle the tests that come out of it?
So this is a graph that came out in the Science Bulletin, by Dr.
Zhu and colleagues that I really think is nice, and it sort of balances.
Almost all of these multi-cancer early detection tests that we have right now have
very high specificity, but we're still a little
bit failing on the specificity side.
Just as a component of this as well, though, it's important to talk about that the
tumor of origin is a very important component of this.
Unlike mammography, you know what you're screening for.
In this case, we also need the accuracy of the prediction.
And just as a reminder, I just put some stars here on sort
of well-considered sensitivity and
specificity for our current screening programs.
And specificity is not quite as high as maybe some of the
early detection tests out there, but the sensitivity of these tests is still a
little bit higher than what we are currently working at.
So what we're going to talk about today, and I'm joined by two really exciting
experts in this field, is maybe what we need to do is start to move the needle
forward by considering other modalities besides just cell-free DNA,
which has been the
most studied modality so far. So we're going to start with Dr.
Martin Taylor, who's going to talk to us about one such possibility, using
LINE1 as an early detection tool.
Thank you so much, Dr. Maxwell. It's really great to be here.
It's an honor, and thanks to the organizers and Dr. Maxwell for inviting me.
So I'm going to talk about LINE1, a pan-cancer biomarker of carcinoma and high-risk
precursors. I'm assistant professor at Brown University, where my
lab works on LINE1 mechanism, as well as using it in cancer
detection. So I'll briefly go through what LINE1 is, what its
ORF1 protein is, why we think it's a useful biomarker.
I'll go through the technology, which to summarize, is a low-cost,
sensitive, and specific cancer biomarker that could either be a standalone
test in a screening paradigm or monitoring paradigm, or could work
as part of an MSI test. We use ultrasensitive
single molecule detection of the LINE1 encoded ORF1 protein from
biofluids for cancer detection. It is a unique
biomarker because of the transposon biology.
The LINE1 is pervasively expressed in cancer and not in healthy tissues, and I will
show you that. And the assays are very inexpensive and use very little
blood and can be run in under two hours,
which makes them quite different from many of the other platforms and potentially
could find them a unique niche. So I'll go through the assay.
I'll tell you some of the future things we're doing, where we can look in other
kinds of biofluids, where we've shown some utility in cancer monitoring, and
what we're trying to do in the detection space.
So, actually only 2% of the genome is
protein coding genes or protein coding exons, even less than 1%.
The rest has been called the dark genome, and we only know the function of a
fraction of it.
But half of it is roughly three million copies of the same few
retroelement virus-like self-copying sequences over and over
again. And of those, in humans, only one is still active.
It's called LINE1, and it's a virus-like self-copying parasite,
and we've been evolving with LINE1 and its precursors for more than two billion
years. It is conserved to plants. And at the end of
a two billion year host parasite arms race, our normal healthy
tissues are extremely good at keeping LINE1 off.
But pervasively in diseases of aging and especially in cancer, LINE1
becomes de-repressed and turns on, and this has multiple negative
consequences. First, LINE1 causes sterile inflammation
through a process that was called viral mimicry.
There was a session on that yesterday, and actually Kate Chipkin Ellie's here,
who's one of the first people who discovered that.
Secondly, LINE1 is a mutagen. It's trying to copy and paste itself someplace else
in the genome. And in addition to the canonical mutagenic
insertions, which themselves are a problem, we now understand that that actually
only represents a very small fraction of attempted insertions, and that LINE1 can
cause DNA damage and chromosomal instability on its own.
And these together have-Been thought to contribute to the
pathologies of a number of common human diseases of aging, and especially cancer.
And then specifically in cancer, our work with Kathy Burns has showed that when
LINE-1 is turned on early in carcinogenesis, before
P53 is mutated, and I'm about to show you that that happens quite pervasively,
LINE-1 causes a very profound P53-mediated growth arrest,
which can cause positive selective pressure.
And we think that this may explain, at least in part, why P53 mutations are so
prevalent in cancer.
So the goal of my research program in general, and of using
LINE-1 for an early detection test, is to prevent or slow these
diseases or find them earlier when we can intervene, and also to develop therapies,
which I won't talk about today.
So,
we've known that LINE-1 could be involved in cancer and could play a role since
1992, when Vogelstein and colleagues showed that a
LINE-1 had jumped into an APC gene, disrupted its function, created an
adenoma that led to a colon cancer.
But it wasn't until, with Kathy Burns, we made the first monoclonal antibodies to
LINE-1 and stained around 1,000 cancers at Hopkins, that it became clear that
this was not just a one-off thing, but actually that LINE-1 was pervasively
expressed across many different types of cancer.
And you can see, for example, in this colon cancer, the cancer stained strongly
for the encoded ORF1 protein. It's a chaperone protein, and the
adjacent normal tissue from which the cancer arose is negative.
And this was true across all of the tissues that we studied.
The normal tissues do not express LINE-1, and cancers do.
And then in the intervening 10 years, I became a pathologist.
We stained a lot more cases, as did a number of collaborators, especially in the
gynecologic space. And what we learned was that actually our initial estimates were
underestimates, in part probably because of tissue quality, in part because we
hadn't really learned how to run the assays very well.
And as we did that, what became very clear is that across major carcinoma
types, LINE-1 expression is a hallmark of cancer.
Almost all carcinomas from major types appear to express the LINE-1 ORF1 protein.
For example, this gastric cancer, this is an intestinal type.
You can see that the adjacent glands are totally negative.
Same thing is true in this head and neck squamous cell carcinoma, where the
overlying epithelium and surrounding lymphoid tissue are negative.
And it's not just advanced cancer.
It actually happens starting in early precursors, early lung cancers,
precursors of pancreas cancers, STIC lesions of the ovary in the
fallopian tube,
and colonic adenomas, which I'll come back to in a minute, are pervasively LINE-1
positive. And again, in immunostain after immunostain, the normal healthy
tissue is negative.
We showed that in Barrett's esophagus, where clinically...
I'm a GI pathologist in practice, and
we're really bad at esophageal cancer prevention.
We are bad at both finding the lesion, because it's a flat lesion that goes all the
way around the esophagus, we can't biopsy all of it.
And then when the biopsies come out, if you put three expert GI pathologists
together, we mostly actually disagree about the cases that matter, the intermediate
cases. Everybody can call cancer, everybody can call normal, but the intervening is
very challenging. And what we found with a
cross-sectional cohort of 72 cases, that LINE-1
pervasively marked the high-grade dysplasia, either the RNA in
situ hybridization, which I show here, or the protein levels, and it
was also
pervasive in low-grade dysplasia.
And of the indefinite cases where the GI pathologist, we can't call the case, we
decide there's probably something wrong, but we're not sure that more attention
should be paid. Five of the nine cases were positive for the RNA, the protein, or
both. All five later went on to develop high-grade dysplasia, the high-risk
precursor. So we think in summary that LINE-1
represents high-risk precursor lesions.
And in the stomach and gastroesophageal cancer, it's not just at the
junction in the stomach. This is an early T1
diffuse type gastric cancer we got from Jeremy Davis at the NIH, now at Maryland,
and then similarly in intestinal precursors.
And I would just point out the intestinal metaplasia here, which is also a
recognized early precursor, is negative.
So you have to get to a higher risk state to turn on LINE-1, at least to a
level that we can see it at the immunohistochemistry level.
So we just stained with Fazilet Yilmaz, a pathologist at Brown.
We just stained a cohort of 82 polyps from 46 patients.
In the MSS pathway, the traditional adenomas, actually all of
them were positive, and of the serrated pathway, 19 out of
20 dysplastic polyps were positive, whereas only about half of the
sessile serrated adenomas without dysplasia were positive.
And intensity of staining increased with dysplasia degree,
indicating that LINE-1 expression is increasing throughout the carcinogenesis
progression. Pervasively, none of the normal stained.
So, in the colon, LINE-1 expression appears to be extremely
pervasive, starting from the adenoma stage, and increase and mark
higher-risk lesions.
So going back to 2013, when Kathy and I started getting all
of these immunostains back positive, we wondered if we could detect ORF1 in the
blood. We had two non-overlapping antibodies.
We got some blood from the cancer center. I made an ELISA test.
It worked pretty well, and we never saw any LINE-1, and we moved on.
Then, a few years ago, I met David Walt at a meeting.
David Walt had invented microwell technology, which in addition was used
to found a company called Illumina that I think everybody here has heard of.
The microwell technology works by developing small wells that are
sized to hold at most and no more than one bead.
And what we do is we make essentially a sandwich ELISA, where we take
a bead and we put an affinity capture reagent on the bead, bind
into a biofluid of interest, in this case, blood or serum, and then wash
and come in with an enzyme labeled detection antibody.
We then load the beads into the microwells, with a fluorogenic substrate,
seal the wells with oil,
and simply read outIndividual molecules by counting
fluorescence. And the assay can count one or more molecules in a well.
As such, you make an assay that's between 1,000 and a millionfold better than a
conventional ELISA. It's very good, a single molecule, low-level detection level.
We applied it to a very first-generation assay.
We applied it to about 1,000 samples from
many different sources. And in the healthy patients, of
406 patients, 402 of them are sitting down here
at the limit of detection, undetectable.
One man, who has a screamingly high value, thought he was healthy when he donated
his blood to our biobank, and six months later was found to have an advanced
prostate cancer metastatic up his spine.
Of course, this was horrible for him, but we were excited because this might mean
that we could find cancer earlier.
We knew very little about these other three patients, but we were worried about
them because across the roughly 600 cancer patients that we
assayed at this test, half of them were positive for the line one protein in
their blood. Importantly, we did not detect OR1 in older patients up to
95 years old. In 30 patients with chronic liver disease, one out
of the 30 was positive. That patient went on to have a hepatocellular carcinoma
later. We did not find it in autoimmune conditions.
Line one is not de-repressed in COVID-19.
If you think that's interesting, I'd love to talk with you about why that is not
true later. And other inflammatory conditions do not
turn on line one. So to summarize this, we have a new kind of extremely
specific but not yet very sensitive cancer biomarker.
Some of these cases are early, and I'm going to come back to this in a moment.
But I just got through telling you that on the tissue level, all of these cases
were positive. But in the blood, we're only detecting half of them.
So we had a very simple idea, which was if we could just make the assay better,
maybe we could detect more of them.
And so we spent a lot of time doing engineering.
We made custom monoclonal antibodies in this application.
We made camelid nanobodies, and I daisy-chained them together in different
orientations to try to find optimal pairs of detection and capture
for OR1. And we made three, what we call second-generation
assays that use different combinations of custom capture and detection
reagents, and we took them over a cohort of 50 women with
ovarian cancer and 50 healthy patients that we received from Ronnie Drapkin at the
University of Pennsylvania and the Basser Center.
And these women, we actually did okay at the initial assay, our
first-generation assay. About 60% of them are positive and
including, very excitingly, four of the six early-stage ovarian cancers,
four of five stage ones and the only stage two.
Stage two is very rare in ovarian cancer.
And these two healthy women are the same healthy women that are positive in all
three, and we don't know why. But in the two newer assays, the
second-gen assays I'm showing here, this first assay increases sensitivity,
catching one more of the early-stage case without harming specificity.
This other assay is actually even more sensitive, but there is a reduced
specificity, but you can even see by eye that there is a cutoff here.
And again, five of the six early stage, 83% are above the cutoff.
And we made a mock MCED test here just combining
HE4, CA125, and OR1P, and you can see that
adding the OR1 test on top of the CA125 and HE4
increases the area under the curve from 0.94 to 0.98 in this
receiver operator setting. So this was pilot utility that we could
show this in a multi-analyte panel, and it might help and be orthogonal to other
methods.
We went on to show that over about 600 cancer patients, that the
second-generation assay had improved performance from our first-generation assay.
It was most sensitive in ovarian cancer and also quite sensitive in colorectal
cancer. In gastroesophageal cancer, where we have a lot of
interest, we were only still picking up about 30% of the cases with the way this
assay was run from 25 microliters of plasma.
So in the intervening time, David's lab developed a new
improved single-molecule assay detection technique called Mosaic.
It's conceptually the same as Simoa.
You still make the same sandwich, ELISA, but instead of needing the microwell chip,
you build up a strong local fluorescent DNA signal on the bead with the DNA
polymerase. And then instead of loading the beads into the chip, you run them
through a flow cytometer. And this has a number of advantages.
First, you don't have to have a fancy Quanterix imaging machine, which is great,
but the chips are not totally free, and this removes the cost of the
chip. Second, about only 10% of the beads fall into the wells of the
chip. So this actually lets you sample all the beads.
And in principle, you could make an assay that's at least 10% better.
So we took
10 healthy patients and 10 gastroesophageal cancer patients from Sam
Klempner's bank. Sam's here in the room.
And
we took these, and they were selected from negative patients from our best assay
from before, and we were able to show that nine out of 10 patients from
cancer and none of the healthy were detectable over what was an assay background
we had at that time. We've since improved the assay to remove the background by
using a barcoding technology where you put in dummy beads together with the correct
beads. And then we're able to show with this in pilot studies with
pancreas cancer patients that we can go from detecting a little over half to
detecting all 12 of them. So of course, we need to run more samples, but we're
excited about this.
So
that's the published data. I'm going to go through a couple of new things that
we're trying to do now. The first is that we wondered whether we could
detect cancer early better by going not into the blood, but actually to the
place where the cancer is. When cancer cells from the GI tract, for
example, or in other organs die, they don't fall into the blood.
They usually fall into the lumen, and it's actually quite clear right now that the
best place for molecular technology for early cancer detection is in stool, where
Cologuard is quite effective, but we're not quite yet there to utility with blood
tests. So we're working with this technology in stool.
And Asya in my lab also had the idea that maybe if we could recover OR1
from alcohol-based fixatives that are commonly used for Pap smears or
for sponge esophageal cancer samples, that might be useful for screening in
ways that blood tests are challenging, that we might be able to make this work.
But of course, in order to make this work, the protein has to be preserved in the
alcohol. I told her there was no way this was ever going to work, but she tried it
anyway, and I was totally wrong.So this is just a
pilot study where she took HEK cells that were expressing LINE1 or
GFP as a control and puts them into our best binding buffer.
Here's the starting cells, and we have some standard curves of our purified
protein. And then she does an IP. And she did the IP
with either the binding buffer or by taking the OR1 that was put into
these different thin prep cytology fixatives and freeze-thawing it, keeping it on
her bench for a day, for a week. She's done the same thing for up to a few months
now, and the protein is completely preserved quantitatively with no loss at all.
Totally unexpected. So we should be able now, we think,
to recover OR1 from these more directly accessible samples.
For example, we would love to be able to detect ovarian and endometrial cancers
early from Pap smears. Actually, the Vogelstein group has shown that
you can detect tumor DNA from Pap smears more than 10 years ago,
and it's just kind of expensive and hard for screening.
But this assay is different in its cost-benefit ratio, we think.
So we're hopeful that that might work.
And then secondly, we took our existing assays in a monitoring
context through a cohort of 19 gastroesophageal cancer patients
undergoing therapy. Anybody who's worked with gastroesophageal cancer knows that
during therapy it's very hard to understand what's going on with the patients.
The tumor, the food, everything goes in the same place. It's inflamed.
It's hard to really know what's going on.
So we had samples at clinical presentation and between 30 and 120 days
on therapy. And what was really striking is that
the assay actually perfectly segregated the responders from the non-responders.
So all of the non-responders, like this unfortunate patient whose
tumors were growing in the liver, you can see here on the axial CT scan,
had either residual, detectable, or an increase in their OR1 level.
I think that one is actually this patient here who increased.
And then
all of the responders had their OR1 fall to undetectable at the second sample,
like this patient whose tumor shrunk really dramatically.
And the reviewer-- We had pointed out that the red dots are higher than the black
dots. The reviewer was very helpful in this case and asked us to look more
deeply. You can clearly see that
the pretreatment biopsies are higher in the
non-responders than the responders.
And we ran this out over colorectal and
gastroesophageal cancer patients, and it was extremely prognostic in the blood.
So if you are OR1 high in the blood, like these red patients here, you do worse.
If you're OR1 low, you do better. Now, this looks just like a ctDNA plot,
and I think we're going to talk more about that later.
We don't know whether we'll just have a cheaper way to measure tumor burden or
we're measuring something about the biology or both.
But one thing that's very curious is we have a cohort of 200 patients with colon
cancer that we've immunostained for OR1.
The 10% or so who had the lowest level that was either undetectable or
questionable, no one has died yet. So we don't know.
We don't have the power yet to do multivariate on that cohort, but we think it's
interesting and potentially useful and may represent something about the
biology. Finally, we took this best bar-coded mosaic assay
over 288 samples from a gastroesophageal trial from
Ji-Youn Lee at Samsung Medical Center.
We can detect about two-thirds of the patients with the SIMOA, but we can actually
detect everybody with the mosaic assay.
And when we look at these patients over their clinical
course at baseline, where they clearly fall during
therapy and where many of them increase afterwards, we can see that the
mosaic assay lets us measure the nadirs better than the
SIMOA assay. And we're still doing the work to figure out if this improved
sensitivity matters.
And finally, in Sam Klempner's trial at Mass General with Sam and
Matt, we have a 41-patient trial with Nilotrifax, which is
a liposomal fulviranox regimen. And we had samples at
pre-therapy cycle one, day eight, which is after just a single dose of
chemo, and then post-op. And the responders are very, very strongly
segregated from the non-responders.
P-value is less than 0.001 after a single dose of chemotherapy.
So gastroesophageal cancer doesn't have any pervasive biomarker up till now.
We're very excited about this. We need to do a lot more work with the time points.
We're comparing it against ctDNA to see if it's additive,
and we're trying to understand exactly what's going on in detail at the tissue
level. So to wrap up, the current status is that OR1 is
expressed-- Sorry, it's a lot of text on this slide, but that OR1 is expressed in
tissue from cancers and high-risk precursors across organ systems.
It appears useful with a limited number of early cases that we have done to
date. It's highly specific, it's low cost,
and it's fast, and it's cheap. It can also be multiplexed using the bar-coded
mosaic technology. So what we need to do to see if this is actually useful
is of course run a lot more samples.
We need to know-- We don't yet have any evidence that there is a normal level of
OR1 in the blood, but we have to figure out if there is, and that's going
to take thousands of samples. We also want to study other biofluids and proximal
samples, as I mentioned, like stool and pap and oral
swabs. And if you have a cohort and you want to know if OR1 could be useful, we
would love to collaborate, so please reach out.
So to summarize, OR1 is a pervasive and specific cancer biomarker due to unique
transposon biology. It's pervasively expressed in cancer and high-risk
precursors.
Separately from this, we're very interested in LINE1 as a potential driver of
cancer that could be targetable. LINE1 and HIV have a shared evolutionary history,
and HIV reverse transcriptase inhibitors inhibit LINE1.
Separate topic for another day. We've made ultrasensitive single
molecule mosaic assays. We can detect OR1 in plasma.
We hope in other biofluids. The assays are under $3 in consumables.
We can run them in two hours. They are sensitive and specific, and they're
likely orthogonal to other methods like ctDNA.
And I guess when I say we, I mean Carly Rubound, who's sitting here in the room.
They appear useful in cancer detection.
They could either be a standalone test or part of a tiered screening algorithm,
where you could repeat samples in longitudinal monitoring or start with OR1
at the start of a screen and follow up with a more expensive test in an MSAT
modality.So thanks everybody for your attention.
I want to thank especially David Walt and Kathy Burns, who've been supporting and
leading this project with me. Fazilat Yilmaz from the staining, Stefan Konney
from David's lab, Mike Rout and Peter Friddy, who made the
nanobodies, Ben Greenbaum, who has done a lot of support of computation,
Tatjana, who did the multivariate analysis, John
Licava, who developed a lot of the reagents with me, Ji-Yun Li with samples, and
many people at MGH, including David Ting, Sam Klempner, Andy Chan, and
Matt Strickland. Thanks so much.
Dr. Taylor, that was an excellent talk.
I'm going to ask you to come out of your slides so we can put the QR code
up there again, if that's possible.
While folks are making their way to the microphone or
using the code, I'm going to take chair's privilege to
start with the questions. It's a really exciting topic.
It's something that we've been interested in for a while
now, too. It seems that the proportion of cancers
that are positive for LINE1 antibody in the
pathology assays sort of correlate with the P53 positivity, and
so do you think these really are sort of hand-in-hand as far as the utility
of LINE1 for early detection will be in those cancers that tend to be more
P53 mutant?
For sure. So it's been well established for a long time that P53 is a tumor
suppressor. Actually, there's really nice work from John Abrams' lab that P53
evolved before multicellular organisms to suppress transposons and only later
developed many of the roles that we know and love.
It is very clear that LINE1 is on before P53 mutation, and what we think is going
on is a three-step process where early epigenetic de-repression turns
on LINE1. Actually, P53 mutation alone is not sufficient to de-repress LINE1.
And then LINE1 does these number of bad activities, including
selecting for the P53 mutation, we think.
And that together then results in a P53 mutation.
And once P53 is mutated, very clearly LINE1 levels
increase, and the cell's ability to survive LINE1-mediated DNA damage
increase, so the mutagen burden increases.
So both the protein and the genomic lesions increase really dramatically
to the point that Ben Greenbaum's lab can actually predict not just if your P53
mutated, but what kind of P53 mutation you have, because
the amount of residual function really strongly predicts how much genomic damage
LINE1 can do.
So yeah, I think it will be most useful in P53 mutant cancers, which
of course are most of the bad actors.
Exactly.
So we have a lot of questions. It's great.
Let's start with this microphone over here. If you can introduce yourself, please.
Yes. Christy Rabollas, I'm a medical oncologist.
So would you see ORF1P screening as a
useful modality in CDH1 carriers or as a tool
for surveillance post-profilactic gastrectomy?
Yeah, we hope both. We actually have a terrific cohort of CDH1
cancers together with Andy Chan and our Stand Up to Cancer-supported
team. And we also have a number of early
gastric cancers from Korea, from Ji-Yun's group.
So we're just getting to screen those now, and we hope that we can see something.
I think there's two scenarios that could be useful.
One is that there's just a binary thing where you develop an increase in ORF1 and
then that is indicative of higher risk.
But there's actually a lot of data, starting, I think, from Steve Skates and
others, that when you serially monitor the same patient over time, even if there's
a baseline level, that inflection from your own level could be
informative. So we're hoping that, especially because the assays are relatively
inexpensive, that you could use this as a twice a year or
some kind of regular monitoring in patients like CDH or Li-Fraumeni or
FAP or BRCA, where you have markedly elevated risk and
where there's a real biologic connection between the genetics
and LINE1.
Thank you so much.
Great. And we'll go over to this microphone over here.
Jeff Fenstrom, Clearnote. Great talk. Interesting technology.
I probably missed it. You speak very quickly, so do I.
Right.
Can you expand more on the comment around
orthogonality to ctDNA and expand a
little bit more on what you might know about the shedding kinetics,
particularly in early-stage cancers?
Yeah. The second one is easy. We know very little.
We would love to learn more. The orthogonality to ctDNA,
actually, many of the ctDNA assays are largely powered by LINE1
promoter hypomethylation, which has been known for 20 years or more to
be a hallmark of cancer. But there's 6,000 LINE
loci out of the half a million that have promoters.
And of those 6,000 promoters, only about 150 of
them can make the ORF1 protein.
Mm-hmm.
And it's very clear that additional dysregulation is required
to actually make the protein and survive in the presence of LINE1.
And I didn't say this in the talk, but if we take a retinal pigment epithelial cell
or a fallopian epithelial cell, for example, and express LINE1 at the same level
that we see in the cancer, they die.
So there's clearly chronic adaptation, and we think therefore, that
that represents a difference in the tumor biology and
that it may be synergistic. Now, we've also done some
immunostaining for the five prime end of LINE1 RNA.
And what we found was 90% of the RNA were positive in colon cancer.
90% of the protein were positive, but the negatives were not the same
patients. So that argues to us that they are going to be separate but
equally useful potentially, or we don't know how equally useful, but separate but
useful biomarkers. Yeah, you.
Great. Let's go to this microphone over here.
Great talk. Hari Eshwen, Johns Hopkins.
I have a few questions, maybe in this bundle together.
So, one is, do you know,
based on ORF1P, the tumor load? And the
P53 thing is interesting. So do you know, in cases of...
How early you can detect?
So specifically, if P53 is not mutated,
it's probably still not a carcinoma, right?
So do you know, based on your test, can you distinguish between
if you detect
ORF1P
What is the specificity? If there's no P53, maybe it's not a tumor.
Yeah. So
we don't know
the kinetics of some of this. So very clearly, LINE-1 is turned on in some
tissues before P53 mutation. In ovarian cancer, we've not
seen LINE-1 on before a STIC lesion is developed, which are almost universally
P53 mutant. So it may be
tumor specific.
And it is important to bring up the limitations of the test, and the biggest one is
that its best aspect is also a limitation, which is that you
don't know what kind of tissue the LINE-1 is coming from.
Mm-hmm.
So we do not have a solution for tissue of origin here.
What we have is what appears to be a very specific anchor of high
risk. So I think that this would have to be a case where either
clinically, we know what's going on with the patient, and we can stratify.
For example, if someone has cancer, we have seen over and over and over again that
as therapy is effective, the LINE-1 levels fall.
This is proof that the LINE-1 is actually coming from the cancer.
But in an otherwise healthy person or somebody with BRCA who's high risk, for
example, if we see it going up, more work would have to be done in a tiered
setting, and we're going to have to do a lot of work to figure out what that is to
figure out what the next step is.
Okay, great. I'm going to add... Oh, okay, go ahead at the microphone.
Yeah. Nice work. So I have a couple of questions.
The first question is,
how about the cancers where the cancer cells don't have access to the
blood?
So how you can detect glioblastoma or kidney cancer?
Yeah.
LINE-1 is actually, for reasons we don't understand, not as high in brain
tumors as well. So I don't think we would be very likely to
detect glioblastoma in the blood with this technology, although we don't know.
But you might be able to detect it in CSF, although by the time you're doing that,
you kind of know there's a problem already.
So it could be useful in monitoring in that case.
We definitely see LINE-1 in what used to be called secondary GBMs or
recurrent GBMs. But yeah, in the brain, there is less
LINE-1, and for reasons we also don't understand, there appears to be less LINE-1
in blood cancers. We don't know why.
Oh, I'm going to--
Sorry to... We have some questions online, so I'll encourage you guys to talk
afterwards just because we only have about a minute left.
Just for the online questions, one of the themes is if
you've looked at earlier stage like DCIS and then if you have an idea
of the sensitivity by stage.
Yeah, we have not. I've showed you basically all of the early cases-
Okay
... that we have run so far.
Okay.
We would love to run those samples, and if you have blood samples from those
patients, please reach out. We would love to do that.
And then the other major theme was differences by age and by race and
ethnicity.
Yeah. Race and ethnicity we know very little about.
By age, in the healthy patients, we saw no difference in the
small number of positives that we had by age.
There is really beautiful evidence that LINE-1 is de-repressed in
senescent cells, which is a hallmark of aging, but we did not
see any evidence as patients get older and presumably had more senescent
cells in their blood, that LINE-1 was detectable, presumably because they're not
turning over and shedding into blood.
We think that this is so specific for cancer because very few other cells are dying
and shedding into blood.
Yeah.
All right. Well, let's give Dr. Taylor a round of applause.
That was a really nice questions and answer session.
Thank you very much.
All right. It's my honor to introduce my former cancer center
director, Dr. Qi Dang.
All right. First, I want to thank Kara for inviting me to participate in
this
session.
She said there were two experts. There are only one expert, because I'm not an
expert in this area. I'm going to treat you, however, to a high-level
review of this area that some of us are really getting
interested in. And then at the end, I'll tell you a little bit about what we are
doing.
This whole area was not familiar to me three years ago because I spent
most of my life studying the Myc oncogene and cancer metabolism.
So
this is my disclosure slide, and I already disclosed the fact this is a
new field to me. So let me just start going back in history.
So the idea of the humoral immune
system can respond to cancer is not new.
Fifty years ago, Lloyd Old, who was a Ludwig Institute
director for a while,
published this paper in PNAS 1976
using old technologies and were able to pick up antibodies in
cancer patients that binds to cell surface
antigens in melanoma.
One of the key discovery that Lloyd made was the discovery of
NY-ESO-1. So the question I phrase here is that can naturally occurring
antibodies impact cancer? And indeed, today we
have TCRs directed at NY-ESO-1
used in the clinic for various cancers.
So in the next
15, 20 minutes, I'm going to cover aspects of
can naturally occurring antibodies
be used for early detection,
for
predicting disease outcome, and then lastly, touch a little bit on
what the future directions hold.
Let me just start out by two major techniques that are used to
detect antibodies in circulating
antibodies in cancer patients.
In the top here, what I illustrate is
a human protein arrays on which over 22,000
purified human proteins produced in yeast
GST-tagged, spotted on the arrays, and you can imagine if
you float over this, either sera or plasma,
and then come back in with a secondary antibody, you can actually image the
spots,
and then that allows for detection of antibodies
against specific proteins.The other major technique is the
use of phage libraries that can
be designed to express specific
peptides that can span across the entire human proteome,
or to express viral proteins or bacterial
proteins as well as the dark
proteome. And just to highlight a few
studies on current state-of-the-art and
perhaps things that needs to be done, this is a paper from a few years ago
looking at
attempting to look at early detection in lung cancer.
So in this study, the investigator looked at control,
benign lung disease, as well as patients with
cancer.
And as you can see in the normal group highlighted in red,
that the prevalence of selected antibodies to
various antigens shown down here, that many of these, in fact, are
increased in cancer patients. And the take home message for me
from this particular paper is that as single markers, as you can see, area under
the curve is okay, but not really great.
So the question is that could we discover in an
unbiased way multiple markers that together might actually increase
area under the curve?
So this is another paper
that looks at early detection for pancreas cancer, clearly an
unmet need. And you can see the numbers of samples shown up here, quite a
few,
to compare this with normal controls and benign.
In this case, this group used a human proteome array that I
already described. And what they did here was to pool a
number of these samples together because it's not
that cheap to run these arrays. So
just to illustrate, one of the hits they got was
CCL20. And you can see area under the
curve, again, not great, but you can see the
behavior of this particular test.
What they did then is actually looked at the gene expression in these
tumors, and then try to use what's being
expressed in PDAC, and then narrow it down
with a number of five autoantibodies.
And here, they're able to get a slightly better area under the
curve. So again, just to emphasize that multiple markers may
be necessary.
This is another
publication looking at attempting for early detection for pancreas
cancer. In this case, they're a candidate
autoantibodies instead of an unbiased
approach. And again, just to illustrate, if you use single
markers,
an area under the curve, versus if you use combination of
multiple markers, you get a better area under curve, which is expected.
Then the other area that's also has unmet need for early detection is
ovarian cancer. This paper particularly asks a question
about anti-p53 antibodies
among these patients. And what they found is that if you compared a
case versus control, cancer patients have higher
autoantibodies to p53 as compared to
CA125, a known clinical marker.
And then if you look over here in terms of the area under the curve,
clearly the combination of the p53
antibody plus CA125 gives you a better area
under the curve. So again, take home message, multiple
markers, somewhat
not quite orthogonal. Now, this paper I'm reviewing for you
actually is a fascinating paper, was published in Cell a number of years
ago, where the investigator asked a very simple question, if you take tissue
sections of various tumors, are there human
antibodies that are bound to the surface of tumor cells?
And remarkably, what they found, as shown on the right here, is that if you look
across various type of tumors
in tissue sections, you can see high amount of
antibodies, IgG bound to tumor
tissues. In the middle here, just to show you the
example of ovarian cancer. On the top here is the
cancer samples. In the middle, a normal fallopian tube, and the bottom
here is a normal ovary. And if you look at the immunofluorescence,
you can see that IgG bound to cells is really
remarkably high, and they have done a wonderful job to
validate this, in fact, is real and not some artifact.
So this is just to show you the quantitative
aspect of this, which is in ovarian cancer, among
the tissues, you can see a lot of antibody bound to this.
And then what they also looked at is if you have
IgG positive tumor cells, that portends to
predict better outcome than those who have low IgG
bound in the tissues. Again, implying that
maybe these antibodies might be functional.
And indeed, what they did in this particular work was to clone
27 of these autoantibodies, and they focus on
metallothionein
protease 14, MMP14. They illustrated if
they use beads that are covered with recombinant
MMP14, that you actually, when you're exposed to these
antibodies, that what happens is you get better phagocytosis if
you're exposed to some macrophages.
And at the bottom here, they illustrate the same antibody actually
can increase NK cell cancer cell
killing through ADCC. So clearly,
a very remarkable
approach to this problem.
Now I'm just going to segue into what you just heard about
in terms of line one. This is a paper, again, published a couple of years ago,
looking at antibodies against ORF1p that you just heard
about.And in this particular paper, what they showed is that if you look compared
to healthy control,
particularly in pancreas and liver cancer, there's an increased
amount of
these antibodies probably reflecting what you heard before.
If you have more antigen floating around, perhaps you have built
antibodies to this. Then on the right, I just want to illustrate it, and in fact,
they look at healthy individuals and look for these
ORF1p autoantibody, and there is an
age-dependent increase in the amount
of circulating autoantibodies. So if you look on the right among
cancer patients, clearly you can see very clearly that the
amount of these antibodies really are highly elevated, perhaps
reflecting the load of the
circulating antigen.
So basically, the conceptual framework here, as you heard
previously, that line one gets de-repressed, antigens are expressed,
antibodies are made, and perhaps it could be used for early detection.
So this work remains to be established.
Then I'm going to turn your attention to microbial antibodies, in this
case, using the PhIP-seq or phage IP.
This is a paper that came out of NCI, where they look at
individual who are at high risk for HCC and those who have frank liver
cancer. So they compare normal control, at-risk patients, and
also liver cancer or HCC patients.
So they first validated this PhIP-seq, in fact, has very good
readout. So basically, the way this is done is you
immunoprecipitate using either sera or plasma.
Once this is precipitated, then you amplify the
DNA sequence from these phages, and then by next-gen
sequencing, you actually can determine what the peptides are being pulled down
by the sera or plasma. And here they just
show that sample size,
in terms of the number of species, that is antibody
against species, actually increased by sample size, but it saturated out quite
quickly.
And then importantly, what they found is that there is a viral
exposure signature by, if you look over here, that
many of these individuals, in fact, have very high antibodies to
herpes virus, for example, and other viruses.
But what they did was to determine this viral exposure signature.
And if you look at the AUC for AFP or
alpha-fetoprotein, known marker of HCC,
clearly the alpha-fetoprotein does not
compare to this viral exposure
signature. Importantly, what they have is longitudinal
samples of those patients who are at risk.
Some of those
remain cancer-free, and others actually develop HCC.
And what you can see here are individuals who are
cancer free, and they looked at the viral signature that did not change.
Interestingly, those who were at risk, their baseline was
already increased, and then it slightly increased over time
as you basically follow these individuals before they were
diagnosed with HCC. So clearly, this is an approach that could be
used potentially for early detection.
And then the question is whether these same microbial antibodies actually might
predict treatment response. So this is a paper that just came out last year
using the exact same approach. In this case, they look at
HCC patients who've undergone immunotherapy to see
whether this can be predictive. And this is just
the hits they got from the PhIP-seq in terms of antibodies against
various viruses.
And remarkably, what they found is that if you
have a high antigen score, meaning that you have a
lot of antibodies against these viruses, actually the
survival probability is quite low, as you
can see here. Then they validate this with an
independent cohort, and again, it holds up that if you have high exposure to
these various viruses, presumably reflected by
antibodies against them, that actually this portends poor prognosis.
And then this paper is also another remarkable paper
where they took an unbiased approach to ask the following
question: Are there autoantibodies that would predict
checkpoint inhibition response among patients with
various type of tumor cancers, melanoma, lung
cancer, or renal cell carcinoma?
And what they
found by this
unbiased approach is that clearly if you look at the number of
autoantibodies among cancer patients versus healthy
controls,
those cancer patients actually display many more
autoantibodies. That's the first lesson.
But then when they drill down to specific antibodies, what they found
is that anti-interferon antibodies are very
prevalent in those who are good responders.
So what does this mean?
Well, they surmise that perhaps with prolonged
interfering exposure, that actually that's immunosuppressive.
So they went into the mouse using the CT26 colon
cancer tumor model. In this case, what they did was to
ask the question, if you use combination checkpoint therapy, and then
you block either the interferon receptor
or anti-interferon alpha itself.
What you can see here from this tumor growth curve is that
control checkpoint therapy alone, in combination, clearly
there is a functional significance to these
presumably autoantibodies to the patient correlating with better outcome.
Now, this is not completely surprising because during the COVID
pandemic,
Paul Pacira and his colleagues actually showed
thatIndividuals that goes into
ICU and never made it out, and they were able to collect all the sera
from many cohorts. And what they found interestingly is
those patients who have very poor outcome of
SARS-CoV-2 are those with very high antibodies
against type one interferon. Again, hyperinflammatory
or unable to deal with the infection.
So what about the future direction?
So this is where I want to introduce our
CRUK Grand Challenge
team, which was just awarded.
And this is led by Paul, among nine
investigators across Europe and United
States.
And the aim of this particular
study is actually to do an unbiased,
very large atlas to
measure antibodies against self, so autoantibodies against
neoantigens or neo-self, and then lastly,
non-self or infectious
agents.
We will also build the dark proteome for the FIP-seq for this as well,
so it's quite ambitious.
Just to illustrate to you that this is a study that we did together,
using samples of Vietnam
of patients that either have hepatitis, cirrhosis, or
liver cancer. So in this case, 60 patients with
cirrhosis, 60 with
hepatitis, and 120 with HCC. And this is
a publicly available
website that you can go in and look at.
And basically,
you can look, for example, the hits for the
FIP-seq is shown here as well as things that we find on a human
protein array that distinguishes between
HCC versus those who are control or those who have
cirrhosis or hepatitis.
And just to illustrate,
just very briefly, the data that we're looking at is that if you look at
principal component analysis of all the autoantibodies that were
picked up by the human protein array, you can see that
with this PC analysis, that many of the HCC
patients in fact segregate away from the patients
with either cirrhosis or hepatitis,
indicating their unique patterns of autoantibodies
associated with liver cancer. And this is a heat map, again,
just to illustrate this point, where for each of the samples to see how
closely they related to the other samples.
You can see in the blue here is a cluster among HCC
patients. And then all in the red here are all the
samples that cluster together are those that are
associated with cirrhosis or hepatitis.
So,
what are we doing with this atlas? So basically, through the funding of CRUK,
we will actually study
16,000 or over 16,000 individuals to create this
atlas.
And if you look at the type of individuals we'll be looking at,
this includes, for example, high-risk
individuals with genetic predispositions such as
p53, MSH, or BRCA
alterations, and some of this actually is done in collaboration with Kara.
We'll also look at heavy smokers who don't get cancer versus those who do,
obese individuals, and then there's a cohort of centenarians
of over 1,000 individuals that were also collected, as well as
identical twins that will be studied.
In this particular study, just to assess the
basically false negative, false positive, we're also going to go into the general
population to get the background on all these autoantibodies to
see what's noise versus signal. And finally,
we have a number of cohorts that looking at checkpoint therapy,
neoadjuvant studies, for example, to look at whether
baseline autoantibody patterns actually will predict
outcome. In fact, just very briefly,
a study that we're doing using samples at Hopkins of
patients who have HCC who are either responder or non-responder
according to overall survival. We now have picked up
a number of antibodies that are associated with
good outcome, and one of these actually binds to a protein that is a
chaperone for presentation of PD-L1 on the
surface of cells. So clearly, there are going to be functional
antibodies we'll discover. So basically, we hope to
discover protective antibodies versus those that are deleterious, meaning that you
have them, actually makes it worse.
And then finally, in acknowledgement,
our collaborators in Vietnam, in Hanoi, Vietnam, we got all the
samples as well as the Grand Challenge team shown here.
And then stay tuned as I learn about
this field. So thank you very much for your
attention.
That was an excellent talk, Dr. Dang.
I'm going to ask you-- Oh, they put it right up there for us.
And so as folks are making their way to the microphone,
would you like to ask a first question, or else I will?
No, you should go.
Okay. So,
I'm very excited to see the humoral side of our immune system getting
some recognition as there are the whole T cell things.
It's important, too. However, one of the things I was really
struck by with your slides is it seemed like particularly with the
microbial response that, I was trying to wrap my hand
around whether or not it's just sort of a response in general or if there was
a specificity to it. So for example, you had HCC patients,
but you had antibodies to, say, Strep pneumo.
So I wonder if you could comment on the causality versus-
Yeah. So the authors of these papers surmise that perhaps
additional infection actually might
createFurther inflammation that and could trigger
HCC, for example.
Why these individuals actually in the second study
have, is predicted for response, that's a little bit less clear.
I have one as well. Dr. Dang, it was a great talk.
One question about the interferon response.
We've gotten quite interested in that because when line one is on, it creates a
strong interferon response as well.
Is your thought about that, or maybe from the authors, that
the interferon antibodies are contributory, or are they
protective?
So in the case of the study that came out of UW
is that it's protective. So those people that actually have high
antibodies, in fact, did better with immunotherapy response.
But conversely, if you are patients who get COVID, actually
it makes it worse.
It's interesting. And then one quick comment.
I'm really glad you brought up the line one autoantibodies.
With Thomas Muslin, we had actually discovered these in lupus patients
before,
and Dr. Gudkov followed up. There is one technical limitation in that
paper, which was that the way the OR1 protein was purified, it's refolded
from inclusion bodies. So we think that if we went back and did this, and we've
been meaning to do this with higher quality, clean, monodisperse
protein, we might have less signal in the healthy patients because they saw much
more signal in the healthy patients than we did.
So, we're really interested that this might be something that could
be improved. Although it's striking in their findings.
Some patients have titers of one to 10 million that you could see.
Even though this is a question session for me, I'm going to ask you a question.
Since I didn't get a chance to ask you, which is the following.
Have you looked at rheumatologic patients to see if
their line one protein levels are high?
Yeah. So this work has really been led by Thomas Muslin at UW.
And,
in lupus especially, there are monogenic lupus-like diseases like
Aicardi-Goutieres syndrome that are characterized by derepression and failure to
control line one. And in patients with sporadic lupus especially,
line one proteins are detectable in lupus neutrophils, but not in healthy
neutrophils.
Also in RA in some cases. So it is one thing we're going to have to be aware
of as we're looking for line one, is that there is this autoimmunity double-edged
sword, like a viral infection that we can't clear.
But I think the autoantibody side is going to be interesting, especially with these
enormous arrays that you're talking about.
That's really great. I'm actually not sure who reached the microphone first, but
I'm going to go over here to my right first.
All right. Thank you very much. Karen Anderson, ASU.
First of all, I want to thank you for what you're going to be doing on the Atlas
project. I think that sort of comprehensive look over lifespan and
over populations and over antigen types is
going to be really important and to inform us about how B cell
immunity influences disease.
One of the challenges that we have in this field is that all of the studies on B
cell immunity are really occurring in the absence of any
look at T cell immunity, right? And this is not what happens naturally.
So my question is, are you thinking about HLA typing these individuals?
Are you thinking about a more sort of integrated, comprehensive look at the
adaptive immune profiles?
Yeah. So absolutely, yes. So we're actually connecting with a CRUK group
that actually are doing TCR work. So we want to see whether
there's a correlation between TCR
right sequences and the type of antibodies. So it's absolutely.
We really want to know, for example, with TLS being predictive
of good outcome for many of the cancers, there must be a
relationship between adaptive T cell immunity
crosstalk and B cells. So it's a whole new area I think is going to
emerge from this.
Okay. Let's go to the microphone over here.
My name is Christine Berg. I'm from the National Cancer
Institute, retired.
This is less of a question than something, and a resource I
wanted to make available. The Early Detection Research Network
has the probe design for development of
early detection biomarkers, and Phase III
is analyzing specimens collected prospectively
prior to diagnosis. And so the National Lung
Screening Trial has heavy smokers, three rounds of
screening, blood storage. So you could go there and
look. And the PLCO has
only 111 ovarian cancers with
pre-diagnostic blood. But both of those
resources are available.
You can apply. It takes a little while, given it's
the federal government. It's a little slow, particularly in this
current era. But I just wanted to make the whole audience aware that it's
available.
Yeah. Thank you for bringing that up.
I was going to ask you a question, how quickly can we get it?
So, just to take one question online.
I think again, for all of this, I think there's so much interest as we're
expanding these panels into making sure that we're really assaying diverse cohorts.
And so, Dr. Dang, can you speak to the geographic origin, and
the diversity of the sample that you're going to be studying?
Yeah. So, as you can see, we have a good reach into
Vietnam. I'm actually Vietnamese, so I have good connections.
And so we'll have those cohorts. But then, at
least across Europe, we're going to be seeing quite a few samples in Europe.
And then we also have connection to the Middle East, so we'll have cohorts
from there as well. So I think we'll find out whether there are
geographic differences as well, as you know.
Let's go over to this microphone here.
Yeah. Thank you for the talk. My name is Dan Gerona from Wake Forest.
I was curious, in the pre-cancer benign cystic condition, are you going to
have any tracking of patients over time, just to see-
Yes. Absolutely. In fact, Kara can fill you more because Penn
has a really good panel of longitudinal
samplesAs well, before diagnosis and diagnosis,
that's one of the collaboration we have actually to look at
BRCA, Lynch syndrome, and Lynch armini.
So yes, absolutely.
Awesome. Thank you.
I will take another. We'll do another online question.
And so another question is how folks with infection are going to
sort of incorporate in here, and do you need to sort of assay some of those
folks, and how do you incorporate that into this project?
Yeah. So basically,
the aspiration here is that we're going to go into UK Biobank-
Mm.
Which also has a lot of actual clinical
infection history. And then we're going to use the FIP-seq, the
VirScan on every sample to look at viral
and bacterial exposure among all these samples.
So I think we're going to be able to tease some of these out quite clearly.
Another question, I guess, again, thinking from the false positive standpoint, is
how clonal hematopoiesis
patients might be affected here, if they may have
autoantibodies that might be difficult to tease apart.
Yeah, great question. We don't know anything about that, but certainly that was not
considered. But I think that perhaps even with clonal
hematopoiesis, there may be autoantibodies that's associated
with clonal hematopoiesis. Nobody's looked at that.
The last question, I apologize to the person who put it in here.
I'm not totally sure. I'm just going to read it word for word.
"Are patients with anti-tumor antibodies affected in terms of the
biodistribution of therapeutic antibodies?" I think that
maybe means does it affect when you're giving a therapeutic antibody?
I'm not sure I really know the answer to that.
Yeah.
Because I think if I understand the question correctly, if these antibodies are
already binding to tumor cells, what about therapeutic
antibody? Yeah.
Yeah, I think that's how I understood the question as well.
I just have one other question, is as you're doing these large groups of
patients, how are you thinking about patients with autoimmune
diseases or pre-autoimmune diseases or at risk for autoimmunity?
How does that work versus patients with risk for cancer?
So one of the very first study we're going to do is actually to validate some of
the technologies by using autoimmune
disease patients as positive controls.
Strong positive controls.
Strong
positive. Actually, so this is actually being done.
That's great.
Yeah.
All right. Well, if there's no further questions, thank you so much.
All right. So I get to wrap us up here.
And one of the kind of cool things about being asked to be on the educational
committee is you get to have a platform to talk about what you want to talk about.
And so I'm going to plan to try to tell you today why I think
studying high-risk patients and patients with inherited cancer risk
really is the ideal patient population as we're going
further with studying all of these types of assays.
Because I think one thing that is clear from the two talks that we just heard is
that a multi-modality approach with a lot of different assays is really going to
be critical as we think about early detection going forward.
So I wanted to just be-- Haven't talked at all about cell-free DNA in this
session. And so just to sort of summarize some of the big studies that have come
out, and I'm sure are going to be focused on quite a bit in this
meeting this year, are the PATHFINDERS study, and then SIMPLIFY was
a study that also used the Galleri cell-free DNA methylation test.
And then I just put on here another study called K Detect,
that used a different assay that uses a multimodal cell-free
DNA approach. So Galleri, as we know, uses methylation, whereas
MassSPOT is an assay that's using multiple different factors of cell-free DNA.
And the exciting part of these assays, of course, is because we do see
very
nice
positive predictive values and negative predictive values and decent specificity
and sensitivity. So as I showed at the beginning of this session,
thinking about what we currently do for screening, I think it's pretty clear that
cell-free DNA assays are going to play a role similar to a lot of the things
that we do, and they have the advantage of having multiple cancers that we
can detect. The problem, however, is that the studies that
are currently being done in large numbers of
people find very low rates of cancer in these
populations. So these are the cancer signal rates and the cancer
yield rate. These are thousands of people study to find just a
handful of cancers. SIMPLIFY took the approach of asking, "Okay, if
we add this multi-cancer early detection test to people who are coming in with
symptoms, non-specific GI symptoms, non-specific lung
symptoms, weight loss, fatigue, would that increase the yield?" And of course
it does. However, these are still low rates of
individuals having cancer. And really, I think one of the
issues about as we expand the number of assays is
how do we scale this financially?
So the argument for studying MCEDs then in patients with inherited risk.
So as I just showed you, the actual incidence of a
cancer in any general human person varies significantly
by age. But even by age 50, an 80-year-old individual in
a year only has about a 2% chance of getting cancer.
And that correlates as a cumulative risk of about 30% over
their lifetime. In comparison, if we think just about the two most sort
of commonly discussed cancer risk syndromes, BRCA1 and 2 and Lynch
syndrome, BRCA1 and 2 in Lynch patients have lifetime risks of
certain cancers that can approach 90%.
I get the argument a lot, but these syndromes are so rare.
How are we going to be able to get enough cohorts in order to be able to study
them? This is work that we did for a totally other reason, is we basically just
looked at what is the population frequency of pathogenic mutations in a lot of
cancer risk genes using the NOBAN database.
And these mutations are rare. However, they're not that rare when we think
about the scale at which genetic testing is currently occurring in the United
States. So BRCA1 and 2 mutations occur in approximately 1 in 400
people. Lynch syndrome occurs in approximately 1 in 300.
And now that we are testing more and more cancer patients, we are
finding more and more family members who are unaffected, who can
then, therefore, serve in a lot of these early detection
studies.So my lab studies
P53 in the germline context, and as a clinician, I take
care of patients with Li-Fraumeni syndrome.
So I've been very excited. Dr. Deng is one of the folks who is
excited to study our cohort, among others, and then some other studies that
we'll talk about at the end because I think that Li-Fraumeni patients really do
serve as an excellent cohort for the study of multi-cancer early
detection assays. So for folks that don't think about Li-Fraumeni syndrome on a
daily basis like I do, Li-Fraumeni syndrome is due to germline mutations in the
P53 tumor suppressor. It is nearly 100% penetrant.
And for those of you who went to medical school who are probably my age or older,
you were probably told, like I was, that you would never, ever see a patient with
this syndrome because it was so rare.
You may also think that this syndrome only affects kids, and that if someone didn't
have cancer as a kid, they couldn't possibly have Li-Fraumeni syndrome.
However, we found as more genetic testing has occurred that that's not
true. And even this older database shows that by the age of
20, an individual born with a germline pathogenic TP53 mutation, while
they have a cancer risk of 20%, that means 80% of the
time, someone born with a P53 mutation does not get a childhood
cancer. That said, by the
end of their life, a Li-Fraumeni patient does have a near 100% penetrance,
particularly for women, because of the high risk of breast cancer, and about
70% of men with germline P53 mutations get a cancer in their lifetime.
In addition, Li-Fraumeni patients get all the cancers that we
might be interested in studying. So again, Li-Fraumeni patients get
some very rare pathognomonic cancers as kids.
For example, choroid plexus tumor, anaplastic
rhabdomyosarcoma, adrenocortical cancer.
And then in the sort of young adulthood, there's a number of sarcomas that we
actually do see outside of the Li-Fraumeni population as well.
Brain cancers start to pop up. But as Li-Fraumeni patients age, they get
the cancers that everyone else does. They just get them earlier and more often.
For example, prostate cancer, lung cancer, pancreatic cancer, and colon
cancer, and obviously breast cancer is very common in our Li-Fraumeni patients.
So thinking about this, my colleague and now collaborator,
Trevor Pugh, along with his then graduate student, Derek Wong, who is
now at the Children's Hospital of Philadelphia, decided to stand up an early
detection test in patients with Li-Fraumeni syndrome.
This is a cell-free DNA test, and
they
think about this, I think a lot of the ways many of us think about is that
multimodality is really the key here.
And so regardless of thinking about other analytes,
even within the cell-free DNA, we're probably going to need to be assaying a
number of components of the cell-free DNA.
So the approach that was taken in this publication that's now a few years old in
"Cancer Discovery" is that they did targeted sequencing of cell-free
DNA, shallow whole genome, and at that point, methylation via an
immunoprecipitation assay. There's been a lot of
further technologies in this field, but at this point in time, this was using an
immunoprecipitation assay. And then they did a number of unimodal
analysis. So looking, okay, what about single hits of mutations in the
genome? What about copy number and fragmentomes?
What about methylation? Looking individually to see how they would
perform in a cohort of Li-Fraumeni patients, and then did an integrated
multimodal analysis. This was a small study.
It was 89 patients looking at P53 wild type
healthy controls, and then also Li-Fraumeni patients who did not have
cancer and patients who had active cancer, and then those who had a past cancer.
Again, as we see in Li-Fraumeni patients, there is a number of
cancers across the spectrum of the cancers we see in these
patients.
And what they found, basically, to take all of this complicated data,
was what we sort of suspected. Is that you really do improve the
sensitivity and specificity of these cell-free DNA tests in
patients with Li-Fraumeni syndrome by using a multimodality
approach. This here I think is probably one of the more interesting
ones that shows if you look at early stage and then late stage patients, how many
patients had an additional P53 mutation found in their cell-free DNA,
how many patients had different types of fragmentation scores, et
cetera. And you can see that no one assay really
gets everyone. One of the things that also is important to mention as
a limitation or a consideration when you're studying different patient
populations is that one thing that became clear in this study was that the
Li-Fraumeni patient population, just their fragmentome patterns are
different due to their inherited mutation status.
And I think that that's something we do need to think about as we're using a lot of
different cohorts. There may be a lot of things that are affecting
the assays that we're talking about, the line one antibodies, the
fragmentomes, the mutations, autoantibodies, that are population
dependent, either inherited syndrome or some other thing.
And so thinking about who we're comparing our patients to, I think, is really
important as well.
So comparing this study then to these bigger studies, so
Pathfinder and Kay Detect that use thousands of patients.
Also, the CCGA study on which Gallery was initially
constructed, about 15,000 patients.
This pilot study using 89, only 89 Li-Fraumeni patients,
found similar positive predictive values, sensitivities, and negative predictive
values as using these populations of much, much larger
patients. Because the number of cancers identified in the small number of
Li-Fraumeni patients was almost the same as in these large cohorts.
Another advantage to using a patient population like a Li-Fraumeni patient
population and others with inherited cancer risk is these patients undergo very
aggressive cancer screening by imaging.
So you have a built-in gold standard to your study.
So our Li-Fraumeni patients, this is a recent publication in the "Journal of
Clinical Cancer Research." It's not 2015.
It actually just came out in 2025. This is our
recommended screening for both children and adults with Li-Fraumeni
syndrome. I'm also going to use this opportunity to take the plug that kids are
unfortunately not being studied in pretty much any early detection
assay. And while childhood cancer is rare, it is devastating, and I think
it behooves us as a field to make sure our assays are working in children as
well.So when we have Li-Fraumeni patients,
the backbone of our screening is a whole-body MRI.
But in addition to that yearly whole-body MRI, we're also doing
colonoscopies. As females become age 20, we
do breast MRI and mammography screening.
In addition, we're doing blood work, and we're seeing these patients very
frequently.
So how often do these scans find cancers in patients?
And the work that I told you is it real-world.
So this was one of many initial studies
that sort of showed us the utility of using whole-body MRI
in Li-Fraumeni patients. And this study showed that in 578
Li-Fraumeni patients with a baseline screen, 7% of those patients were
identified with a cancer just on that baseline screen.
It does also show one of the difficulties that we have in cancer screening
is that 30% of the patients required an intervention because there's a
lot of false positives when we use imaging.
Another place where we hope really that these multi-cancer early detection
tests will help. So we wanted to ask the question, that's the
initial screen. Maybe all we're doing is catching prevalent cancers when we do an
initial whole-body MRI. So we went on to ask, what about the subsequent
MRIs in our Li-Fraumeni patients?
Are we identifying cancer at the same rate as that initial scan?
So this is a now a few years old study, led by myself and
Dr. Suzanne McFarland, who is my pediatric colleague at Children's Hospital.
And we studied approximately 90 adults and kids who had an initial
scan and then also a subsequent scan.
And you can see that one of the things we were trying to look at was burden.
And for kids, the fraction of screenings that required additional
workup really didn't change between the initial and the subsequent.
But for adults, that really went down a lot with the subsequent, and that just sort
of makes sense. Adults have a lot more ditzels, as we call them, that
once you know what that ditzel is, doesn't require as much intervention.
But it does still point out that approximately 20% of patients are
requiring those interventions.
That said, what we did find is that despite the fact that 20% to 40% of
patients that are getting whole-body MRI do need interventions, the
invasive intervention rate is much lower.
And most importantly for this component, for this talk, is that we're
still diagnosing cancers in about 7% to 14% of these
whole-body MRIs on subsequent scanning of our Li-Fraumeni patients
just because they're at such high risk.
So what kind of cancers are we finding?
This is just a
very dirty review that I sort of put together of 137 of my patients at
Penn, and CHOP, that had 405 sort of
screening intervals. And this is including all of the presenting
cancers, so there's some bias here.
There's a lot of breast cancer because we find a lot of PTEN mutations from our
young breast cancer. But in addition to the breast cancer, we see exactly the
kind of distribution of cancers that I was talking about.
And again, in a five-year period, 45 non-breast,
non-Heme malignancy cancers were diagnosed in this cohort.
This is one of my patients, and I actually need to update his trajectory because
more things have happened to him. These are going to be complicated patients to
study, but they are going to allow looking at the
contribution of new cancer
diagnoses to what might have been happening from the patient's life prior.
So this is a man who I've been following now for a number of years, and he
basically read the Li-Fraumeni textbook. He had an osteosarcoma as a child.
He underwent surgery and chemotherapy for this, became NED.
He's had a whole bunch of benign things happen over the course of his lifetime.
He's also had a melanoma, a leiomyosarcoma,
a non-small cell lung cancer, and then that recurred.
He cleared both of those, and now unfortunately, he has a
new ALK-positive lung cancer. But the point is that this
is the sort of type of patient that we see, and
there's obviously so many interesting questions you can ask about the effect of
prior cancer on things that are circulating in the blood in addition to
the new diagnoses.
And finally, I guess again, taking the ability to use a pitch, this
is a patient population that has a devastating syndrome.
And so any study that we do of MSIDS will help, even while it's rare, an
absolutely devastating syndrome.
And that's because unfortunately, there's still a lot of barriers to screening.
This is a survey that my colleague Suzanne did, looking
at the awareness of screening for Li-Fraumeni families and most
importantly, the financial burdens that many of these patients face with the
radiographic screening that we do.
So with all of this in mind, we established the Edison Consortium back in
2019. We decided to establish a consortium right before a
global pandemic, which may or may not have been the smartest thing to do.
However, we were able to get together this group of folks.
This is the initial
individuals that we established, Brian Crompton, Crescent Scholz.
I've talked about Suzanne and myself, Luke Mason, Pyle Kinchett, the NIH.
And we've since additionally added on some additional collaborators.
And because I'm a VA investigator, we also now have a study open
at the VA. And what we're doing is we're basically longitudinally
collecting patients. We started in 2019, and
under the umbrella of some of the other consortiums for Li-Fraumeni syndrome.
And we actually have a memorandum of understanding that we've been able to get all
of these institutions to sign off on so that we can pull all of our patients into
one REDCap in order to have all the clinical information, and then each
institution holds their longitudinal samples.
This is an old table from a Department of Defense grant that we
were awarded in order to establish this rare cancer
community resource that we call the Edison LFS Rare Cancer Community Resource.
This is again, a number of years old and shows that we have
approximately 900 Li-Fraumeni families just in that first six
institutions that we put together in our consortium.
And the number of cancers that are diagnosed down here,
517 patients have had at least one cancer and 435 with two
or more. And then importantly, there's a number of patients who haven't had
cancer.Is this a patient population that wants to do
this? Yes, it absolutely is. This is a survey, again, done by my
colleague Suzanne. And it basically asked how willing would you
be to be involved in a liquid biopsy
prospective study. We've been trying for a while to get
a prospective study funded, but you can imagine it's a difficult
time to get something like this funded.
But you can see that the majority of patients, they basically said,
"Yes, I'd do it, and I'd do it as frequently as you want."
So talking about the multimodality, I just want to use the opportunity that we have
now been able to expand a bit out of just cell-free DNA
into looking... Sorry, not just cell-free DNA, and looking into other
components of the potential immune system response to
cancer in Li-Fraumeni patients. This is a Mark Foundation grant that we were just
awarded. Trevor Pugh is leading this grant with Brian Crompton and Paul
Northcott. And our goal is, again, to really expand on that Edison
resource that I talked about, where we not only have our samples, but
also a centralized resource for the whole body MRIs themselves.
In addition, given the immune response and its importance,
we are going to be looking not only just at can we see T cell
receptor sequences in the blood of these individuals from the cell-free DNA,
but do we actually want to think about doing things like sorting out the
peripheral blood mononuclear cells and looking for clonal T cell responses
there. We're really excited also to be able to partner with Dr.
Dang, looking at the humoral response.
And then finally, the Basser Center and the newly
minted King Center for Lynch Syndrome at the University of Pennsylvania with my
colleagues Susan Domchek, Kate Nathanson, and Bryson Katona, who is in the room.
We're combining a multiple of our inherited cancer
cohorts to do some of these multimodality cell-free DNA
assays. And then I put the plus here because I think this is where we are really
open. We're really excited to work with anyone who has new
technologies on these cohorts that we've annotated really
well over the years.
And so with that, I'll thank my lab and my collaborators and be happy
to take any questions.
While people are coming to the microphone, I can say that you weren't kidding that
we need to run your samples on our assay. It's very exciting.
Yes.
An amazing amount of work to bring together all those patients.
Thank you. Yeah,
just in general, I will say that I'm really interested in the role of
line one in pathogenesis of tumors in Li-Fraumeni patients.
I think that in general in inherited cancer risk, and now this is not about early
detection, apologies to folks in the room.
But I think that we often think that loss of heterozygosity is the first hit
in pretty much all of our inherited cancer syndrome patients.
But in BRCA, that's not necessarily true.
A lot of times, it's thought that the PT3 mutation occurs before the BRCA loss of
heterozygosity, and so it's perhaps that line one dysregulation occurs before
that. And certainly, in patients who are inheriting PT3 mutations, I think that's a
strong possibility. So I think that everything that we're learning,
things from these autoantibody studies, things from line one studies, are also
going to help us understand how these cancers are developing in these patients.
Over here on the mic.
Hi, Phil Bosz, also from Philadelphia.
I can certainly understand the benefit of a blood test over invasive
colonoscopies and EGDs. But does a blood test in
Li-Fraumeni or other inherited syndromes give you any lead time?
Yeah. I think that one of the things that I didn't really point out, too,
is I think that our dream and why we all want to do this is that
we still have false negative imaging scans.
Probably not as much in breast or in colon, but with the whole body
MRIs. In order to just get a human through a whole body MRI in a way that isn't
going to keep them there for eight hours, we're by definition not scanning
every part of the body as well as we would like.
And so, all of us have those examples of misses.
I have a recent patient who on her
whole body had an eight centimeter leiomyosarcoma that on retrospect was a
little something the year prior. And so that's really, in my opinion, where I
think the test will help us, is that the imaging just
still isn't going to be, I think, as good as we could maybe find
something in the blood. I will point out that I do
think that it's an important point when we think about some of our
other inherited risk populations.
Colonoscopies and mammograms work really, really well.
And so whether or not these tests are going to be beneficial on top of those
well-established modalities, I think is less clear.
But where I look at in that is that particularly for breast, it could perhaps
really help us with the false positive rate, who should be biopsied, and most
importantly, when should a woman consider a bilateral mastectomy, and these
sorts of things. These assays might be able to help some of those decisions.
Over here.
Hello. Avery Michelide from Natera.
At one point in your talk, you made a comment like you have to be careful what
you're comparing to.
My interpretation of that was that you were maybe implying that
by focusing on LFS patients, maybe there was something about the cancers
within them that's sort of specific to LFS. Is that at all what you were saying?
I'm sorry to-
Oh, I'm sorry. Yeah. I guess what I was getting at is that, given that we
know that just the fragmentome patterns and the methylation patterns in
Li-Fraumeni patients are different than healthy population, I just suspect that
that's going to be... There's so much variability in all of these assays.
I think that there's going to be some things that we can understand, maybe their
inherited risk. But I think that's exactly why studies like
Cheese study, looking at really large populations is so important
because there could be so many different factors that are affecting the baseline
detectable, the detectivity of your test
with looking then at the patients that you're looking at.
I feel like, I don't know if other people maybe have data for this, but smokers
probably have a completely different pattern of all of these different
markers in the blood than non-smokers, for example.
So you imagine there could be confounders.
I 100% think, yeah. I definitely do.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Over here.
Shaquille from Tempus. So my question is regarding
the testing which you are saying that.
What about if you get an positive test, like you have a positive ctDNA,
but it doesn't show up in imaging. What you will do in that case?
Right. So I think again, that's where
I can use my platform to say that our high-risk patients, I think, are a really
nice cohort for that because, in the general population, I know all of
us have received papers that have talked about the diagnostic odysseys and
how long it takes you get a positive test.
We know that patients have circulating BRAF mutations due to their panin,
for example. They may have a lot of different assays that are
positive. And they're then undergoing a diagnostic
odyssey, where I think having the sort of base, the
radiographic imaging along with the
test that you're testing will be helpful.
Now, what do you do when you find something and we don't have the actual imaging?
I think that's a question for all of us in this space.
Not just for patients with an inherited risk.
And the components of the anxiety of that are going to go
along with these types of tests is very different.
Again, I would just make the argument that patients who have an inherited risk are
sort of inherently used to dealing with this potential
uncertainty, and false positives in the screening that they're
undergoing. And so, I think that's a patient
population that is willing to take that risk, and
understand what that risk really means when we're consenting them to our studies.
And is there a chance of increasing the cadence for imaging for these
patients?
Oh, why don't we do their imaging more frequently?
Honestly, it's a significant
burden financially, and anxiety-wise, and just in general.
And what is the right cadence? Nobody knows.
Thank you.
I've got an online question. In regards to multimodal
detection, for example, in GU cancer where there's another obvious
biofluid, or colon cancer, what do you think is the role for
combining the blood test with the second modality?
Yeah, and I think this is a really
hard point, and you had sort of brought that up too when you were asked about the
brain cancers. So when do we actually assay
CSF in addition?
And again, I think that this is where a patient population that's at higher risk
could be a benefit.
Doing more invasive procedures on high-risk populations is a little bit more
palatable. But I agree. I'm not really sure
how much can we assay. I
think I really was excited about your ideas of using paps and
other things and
esophageal brushings and stuff, and really excited about your work in the alcohol
stability of these proteins, because I think that those are obviously a lot
easier to acquire than certain other tissues.
That's great. How about over here?
Hi, Eric Klein from Grail. Really, really nice work that you're doing in this
population. Really an unmet need.
I wanted to amplify something about the Simplify study, which was the
nonspecific symptom patients in Britain.
What they reported with an initial follow-up of nine months
was a positive predictive value of about 75%.
And with an additional roughly 18 months or 15 months of follow-up out
to 24 months, the positive predictive value rose to
85%, which suggests that this technology can
detect cancer signals before they can be
seen on imaging.
Yeah.
What we've heard from the field with the use of Galleri is just the case that
you pointed out, which is there's a little something on an X-ray
that a radiologist, in the absence of knowing anything else
about the patient might say follow it.
But if you have a positive ctDNA signal, it deserves a further
evaluation.
Yeah, no, and thanks for bringing that up.
And that's why I really wanted to amplify.
I think, just in general, the higher the pretest probability, we all know this, all
of us who are clinicians who order tests, the higher pretest probability you have,
the more likely that you're going to find something.
And so thinking about these populations versus sort of just everyone, I think, is a
good way to do it.
Right. And part of the utility of the multimodality is that a Galleri
test is still extremely expensive.
Right.
So if we wanted to run that with every-
Yes
... every ditzel on every X-ray or every MRI, we would have a real
problem.
Exactly.
So I think we're going to need tumoral tests-
Exactly
... that are inexpensive, other tests that are inexpensive, and figure out how to
put them together.
Yes.
A question over here.
I'm Omer Chaudry from Abbott Cancer Diagnostics, and
my question is how frequently are these tests
required, both in high-risk population and in general population?
Yeah, I think, again, this gets to exactly what we're talking about, about the
price of the tests and why I focused this session on tests that were
maybe a little bit cheaper and used a little bit less sample.
Because I do think that we're going to be having to do these pretty frequently.
But then, what is that frequency? We don't necessarily
even know that for PSA to be honest or something.
So I don't know if you guys have comments on that for what you're thinking about in
the assays you're working for. If you were asked to do a prospective trial, what
frequency would you want to do? We struggled a lot with this in the trial that
we're putting together for our Li-Fraumeni patients.
We ended up on six months. We don't know if that's right.
Yeah, I think that's beyond my expertise to answer.
I think we're going to have to try and try a couple things and figure it out.
What do you...
I was going to say, yeah.
Yeah, I have a couple of online questions,
two about Li-Fraumeni. One is, do we know why women with
Li-Fraumeni have an increased rate, specifically of HER2 positive breast
cancer?
So, we have a paper that just got accepted
recently, and we think it has to do with the way
the amplifications occur, and
sort of short amplified segments that may be ecDNA driven.
But I think that we don't fully know the mechanism and, maybe,
Martin and I,
Dr. Taylor and I, sorry.
Dr. Taylor and I will figure that out.
Maybe it's line one that's helping to drive that.
There's some data connecting line one with HER2.
Yeah.
So it'd be very interesting to look at that together.
Second question here is, what about other rare syndromes like
ATM or-
Right. That's one thing I do want to stress is that, I think
the really high-risk populations are the ones that we should really be focusing on,
that really high penetrance. The moderate penetrance genes are going to be harder.
That said,
I think that it's a possibility, but I do think there's
enough genetic testing happening in this day and age,
that there's enough of the really high-risk syndrome patients that we can study.
And then one last question as we wrap it up here for time.
What role do you think home screening would have, like
Cologuard or blood spot finger sticks,
in general population?
I don't know, and I'm going to say that because we're out of time I can't answer
that question. I thank everyone for your attention
today, and I'm really excited to see how this field moves forward.
Thank you to my other speakers.
Thank you.
It's a tough question.